make it personal so I'm a big believer
in every human being having one word
that defines them and then trying to
bring that to your business and making
your business about your values not just
about the product or service that you're
selling so here at Toronto at salsa it's
all about family and we've been doing
things at the studio to make it more of
a family feel we have a family culture
where people come here not just to learn
how to dance salsa but to feel like they
belong to a community of people and they
make friends and you see people develop
their self-confidence and grow as
individuals along with growing their
dance skills and so we've done things
like put a family tree on the wall and
put the pictures of our instructors and
helpers or senior students on the wall
to make people feel like they belong a
little bit more and one kind of secret
project I've been working on is I hired
an artist to create I wanted a sign
above our tree that's at family so we
had family tree and I commissioned an
artist to make it and put these light
bulbs inside it and we unveiled it at
our helper training event and
unfortunate I wasn't here for it I was
in Orlando on my annual family trip and
so we had it covered up behind a tarp
for a week and a half and I said Alex
you're leading the training you're gonna
unveil the sign and I want you to not
just show it but tell a story as to what
it means to you and why this is here and
we're gonna we're going to roll the clip
of Alex doing his speech but I wanted to
get his perspective quickly on it before
we show you the clip well the first
thing I want to say I was super nervous
just I was I was I started penning
things down about what my speech was
gonna be like and then I just realized
that I tend to do best and when it just
comes from the heart naturally just
comes out so the one thing that I want
to focus on a core of family I just
related to myself I thought but what's
important about family to me and it just
made me realize how much you know I
missed having those family big
gatherings when I was little you know
big dinner table 20 people kids running
around I'm running around causing
trouble and all that kind of stuff right
that a communal experience altogether
and so thinking about tds about this
business
about Toronto dance salsa I realized
that that really is what holds people
together all the volunteers all the
students that come here they come here
because they want to they feel that
they're part of something bigger but
they feel that they belong to something
I carried that sort of that spirit and
so there was about 30 helpers on the
other side of the camera so you don't
see that but you only see me but there's
like 30 people there and they'll as i
was talking people were nodding and
saying yes you know we're part of this
it's it's you know it's good to be you
know with a family you also get to
choose right so yeah so that's a little
bit of the back story there cool well
let's roll the clip I'm so little about
my work experience here te estas muy no
I started courses and a half years ago
basically from a country and my cultural
background is all about large dinners
with your families getting together good
folk speech then when I came to this
country I only had my brother in my mom
here so my cousins my nephews they were
all back home and I really miss them and
one of things that I experienced it
tedious when it started as a student
when it became a he'll work with
assistant and so far has the family
experience and Evan and I with your help
we've really been trying to put that
that TDS is not the main purpose is not
dancing we're dancing we're having a
good time but we all can be here because
we want to feel belong that we want to
meet new people that we want to have a
family
you'll conquer of ourselves validated
validated others and that's what you're
also helpers you're here because at some
point there was a helper there was an
assistant someone that really spoke to
you and said you can do it i believe in
you and you want to carry that on that's
why you're here you're here because you
have heart and you really feel what
family is that's what you've been here
with us and I can't I wish every was
here I can't express how much this means
to me how much just means do Lily all
the instructors all the students the
wonderful feedback that we get the love
and the care you know all of our our
tech this amazing thing really helped us
help us become a better couple you make
a difference in people's lives and I
want you to really not underestimate
them people come here to escape stop
worrying about their troubles to turn
off their brain and just enjoy this hour
hour and a half it doesn't seem like a
lot but it does it was a lot for me and
to have this adopted family that I have
a few and have a heaven it means so much
to me means the world to me this makes
me this feels like home to me and that's
why that's not part of this so much
that's not good morning because I can't
see myself being outside of this place I
love this place and I hope that all of
you stay with this school with us as
much as possible and I hope we continue
to provide you amazing experiences
opportunities for growth and the support
and everything you possibly
this adopted family tds do you like home
so we haven't worked on something this
is super awesome really excited to
announce it really started with the
family okay wait wait yeah yeah yeah oh
my god this is the fault this is right
just like I was always awkward don't
talk about it
okay oh she's breaking my fall
families are students or instructors you
so thank you so much for all the hard
work you're part of our daily lives and
you know we're always do our medicine
for you this is going to see on 24 hours
a day this is going to remind every
personal i'll try every student that we
are about fam that we give equal
opportunity to see him along ok so i'll
accept me this clip while i was in
orlando and he asked me to take a look
at it he was unsure if we should put it
up on her channel or not whether we
should use it or not whether it was good
or not and i thought as a first-time
kind of getting up and giving a speech
it was a really good first effort
there's ways that can be improved but i
thought was a really good first effort
and we're going to share it on the tds
channel and i wanted to share it on this
channel to just as a reminder for you
guys to make your business more personal
right you hear Alex talking about his
brother and moving here and why this
business means so much to him that is
the the the guts of this business of
what makes it successful is a personal
connection that people will make to each
other into the leadership and so I would
HIGHLY encourage you guys to get out
until your story whether it's a youtube
video whether it's right in an article
you're going to be nervous like Alex was
his first time it won't be perfect the
first time I've done five to seven to
ten different versions of like the meet
Evan and my story on my youtube channel
and every time I do it it gets better
and more refined so don't worry about it
being perfect but people will connect to
you and and that's your competitive
advantage as an entrepreneur your
personal story why this means so much to
you because otherwise I'm just going to
go compete on price or buy some product
or service from the big guys because
they have a trusted name and reputation
your competitive advantage is a human
pneus your passion and your story so I'm
really curious to find out what's
holding you guys back from sharing your
story and really trying to be authentic
and yourself in a video or in an about
me page on your website leaving the
comments below cheers to find out I
think could help inspire others as well
to take that leap so thank you guys for
watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon